>> That's good David.
So the de Morgan's law is saying that when we try to distribute negation
over the predicate inside the parentheses that are connected with a conjunction,
then the conjunction becomes a disjunction between the negations of the pre,
predicates. The same would have been true if we had a disjunction here.
When we distribute the negation, it would have become a conjunction here. David,
before we go ahead further, let's remember why we are trying to do all of this.
So do you recall we said in the beginning of the lesson that a logical agent
will have a knowledge base, and then formal rules of inference that will apply
on these sentences as knowledge base. The knowledge base itself may be coming
from many places. Some sentences in the knowledge base may be boot strapped into
the logical agent. Other sentences may be coming from perception. Now when we're
trying to apply these rules of inferences to the synthesis of the knowledge base
it is sometimes very useful to rewrite the sentences in different forms. And
that's what we are trying to do.
These properties will allow us to rewrite the sentences in such a way that we
can in fact apply the rules of inferences that we will see in a minute.